what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so picking up with the second part
of the button I mean I really hope like
in the first video I really hope you
guys dug it because to me like the two
Department is the best thing come out of
DC rebirth right now I mean God because
there's so much cool stuff here
initially we open up with my Johnny
thunder now here's the deal this is this
is huge this is huge it's not the first
time we've seen him but this is huge and
the reason why is because when DC
universe rebirth number one showed up
and really like a red haired Wally West
was traveling around trying to find ways
to anchor himself back to reality
ultimately finding Barry Allen and then
Barry Allen remembered him one of the
people he visited was Johnny Thunder
because Johnny thunder was part of the
Justice Society of America now for those
guys who don't know chronologically the
Justice Society of America was the
predecessor to the Justice League now
eventually DC launched the Justice
League and then they created earth 1
which was a whole different universe the
Justice Society was basically the
Justice League on earth 2 it was
composed of older characters the reason
why this matters is because of the fact
that when DC launched the new 52 the
only indication we had of the earth to
Justice Society basically came in the
story earth 2 but those heroes died off
quick fast and in a hurry because DC was
basically launching the landscape for
like Darkseid war and all that kind of
good stuff and so for the earth to line
the stories were totally separate
characters valve odd different things
like that but it wasn't like Jay Garrick
it wasn't Allen Scott it wasn't any of
those guys they were all gone they were
nowhere to be found and so because of
that fans while some did like earth to
traditional fans of the JSA we're so
upset because the heroes they loved were
basically gone when DC Universe we're if
number one popped up and then Wally West
went to go see Johnny Thunder then the
idea is is DC bringing back Jay Garrick
are they bringing back Allen Scott are
they bringing back those members of the
Justice Society that everybody knows and
loves the question was answered to a
degree when Wally said your job is to
find the JSA and bring them in and so
the implication here is that somewhere
on earth Allen Scott is alive somewhere
on earth Jay Garrick is there now it
could be there in other dimensions or
something like that but it seems like
they aren't alive maybe they don't
remember who they are maybe they haven't
gotten their powers yet whatever the
case may be
well the indication seems to be that
Vera
found there somewhere which is a very
very exciting bit of information again
so because of this we basically focus on
the button from the flashes perspective
from very Alan's perspective and the
question that's being asked here is
what's going on because when he was
investigating you know when he is
investigating that the corpse of earbuds
on keep in mind Barry Allen is a
forensic investigators of forensic
scientists and so his job is to analyze
dead bodies and look for evidence as to
what it was that may have killed him
doubly so now than in any other
circumstance because eobard thawne is
one of the deadliest and most powerful
foes that Barry Allen has I would dare
say
eobard thawne could hold his own against
the entirety of the Justice League and
so if someone had power enough to
absolutely kill him then the question is
who not only that from the words of
Batman he kept shouting about beings how
he saw God how he was terrified now
that's huge because in all the time that
we've seen eobard thawne we've seen him
in almost one circumstance which is to
say he's cocky who's arrogant he sure of
himself he's never scared we've never
seen an infant's of eobard thawne where
he was scared and so the fact that he
saw some force out there that was so
powerful that he was terrified means
that whatever that force is is insane
now what Barry Allen also discovers is
that on this corpse of eobard thawne
it's his own speed force energy now this
is Geoff Johns hinting at several
different possibilities and the reason
why is because of the fact that for
years and years and years and years the
nature of the Flash's powers were that
somewhere along the line he was doused
with chemicals he was struck by
lightning and he gained the ability to
run really fast and that was it that was
just the story of the flash that's his
origin as he'll regain his powers so on
and so forth there was this enigmatic
force called the Speed Force and Barry
was able to tap into it which is how he
ran now what Geoff Johns did in 2009 is
he wrote a story called the flash
rebirth and it was designed to basically
kind of restore Barry Allen back to the
main DC landscape but to also turn
around and provide a little more
information and to kind of clear up all
the past it was really designed if he
just kind of like a jumping-off start
kind of a soft reboot for the Barry
Allen character so to speak but the idea
was a Jeff John said okay so here's how
things work Barry Allen was down with
the chemicals Barry Allen was struck by
lightning Barry Allen learned how to run
really really fast the more he ran the
more he created the Speed Force the more
the speedforce grew the more permeated
all throughout space and time and so
essentially what happened is that where
the speedforce grew to be massive in
size and it's huge source of energy and
because it permeated everything from the
beginning of existence to the end of
existence when Barry Allen was struck by
lightning and doused by chemicals what
he did is he basically allowed himself
to tap into a Speed Force but he had
already created some future point in
time so again it's a little bit a little
weird in terms of how it works but it
still makes sense it's still pretty
reasonable but the idea is that each
speedster has their own energy signature
the Speed Force allows them to tap into
it but the signature of very Allen is
different from the signature of Wally
West the signature of eobard thawne is
different from the signatures of Barry
Allen and Wally West and so because of
that when Barry Allen basically realizes
that his own energy is on eobard thawne
the implication here is that very
himself was the reason why eobard thawne
died which the question had to be asked
why why is very signature there and is
Barry the one that killed him now from
here we get into this little bit of a
segment again where where Barry's
basically talking to that man about how
eobard thawne was ranting about how he
saw God but something else to point out
here and this is something that I didn't
realize when I was initially reading
number one is that eobard thawne
vanished and reappeared but remember
eobard thawne traveled presumably
through Todd now the assumption for me
at the time was that eobard thawne was
just transported to another dimension
where time passes at the same speed so
if he disappeared for three seconds he
was in that dimension for three seconds
and then came back but Batman raises a
really good point he says eobard thawne
ends intrinsic to time so sure he
disappeared for a second and came back
but for him he may have been gone for a
week or a month or years and then just
reappeared again so it creates a really
wild scenario because and that begs the
question what all happened at year
barred Thawne you know was he teleported
away and then he was just held prisoner
for a year and crazy experiments were
done on and then he just came back
freaking out about how he saw God and
then just died like what in the world
happened with him and that's why this is
so cool is because there's so much
speculation that we can do there's
there's so much guesswork that we can
delve into here and so ultimately what
is up happening here is that where the
two of them do share a bunch of
information where Batman says that he'd
been studying the button in the
background between the different
campaigns and scenarios that he had been
in the end he wasn't able to find
anything I mean he had analyzed the
blood sample on the button and searched
every single database he could find you
know the Justice League database Argus
the FBI style labs a whole nine yards
and couldn't find anything now we know
the reason why is because of the fact
that's a blood on the button belongs to
the comedian it belongs to one of the
members of The Watchmen who presumably
come from a different universe and so
Batman's literally searching for blood
that belongs to a person that doesn't
live on his earth and so again it's
really kind of crazy and I mean as far
as that man is concerned this guy's a
ghost this guy is a vision somewhere now
to make things even more complicated for
the flash Batman says the button
interacted with the Medusa mask and he
saw his father now keep in mind Barry
Allen did experience a flashpoint
universe but a flashpoint universe
should be gone
it should not be in existence and so the
question is if versus Wayne you know the
button interacted with Medusa's mask and
Bruce Wayne had a vision of a man he
never met then how did that work how in
the world did that happen is the
flashpoint universe still there is it
still present and so ultimately Barry
Allen also counters by saying that he
had a very similar experience and we saw
this in the flash story is one of these
is why I'm so glad I covered all those
things because again those are all in
that playlist one of the things that he
had talked about when he was you know he
was basically on a mission alongside
while he was is that he basically you
know he had this vision this experienced
where all he saw was the helmet of
mercury and with that helmet came an
unreasoning feeling of absolute hope now
we as fans look at that and say that's
the helmet of Jay guard it it's like the
flash TV show right like it's like the
flash TV show when there was that whole
great big huge crazy thing with the
black hole and then in you know after
that black hole basically came the
helmet of Jay Garrick indicating that we
were going to see Jay Garrick in the
flash TV show which we did and it was AM
is amazing storylines it creates a
really cool scenario because remember
from what we can tell and and how things
seem to be playing out here either Barry
Allen has no knowledge of the Garrick or
Barry Allen never met Jay Garrick and
the reason why I say that is because of
the fact that remember Wally West
basically said everyone everyone lost 10
years out of their life and so it's
entirely possible that the Justice
Society existed that the DC universe was
as we remember it when the new 52 for
Star
the Justice Society was running around
Barry Allen Wally West you know Kid
Flash all the kind of stuff they were
all just one great big huge team and
then dr. Manhattan stepped in screwed
things up and it resulted in the fact
that no one remembers who jay garrick is
nobody remember who Wally West is and so
it's completely possible that where
Wally West was effectively stuck in the
Speed Force before he basically reached
out and Barry Allen brought him back
that Jay Garrick is in that exact same
position but Jay Garrick is not powerful
enough to get himself out of the Speed
Force he's not gassed enough or whatever
the case may be and so it resents all
different kinds of scenarios on what it
is it can take place here all different
kinds of things that could happen now
the cool thing about this too is that we
also get this a little bit of a hint in
terms of what direction it is that DC is
going in and we'll actually talk about
that in the next video but with regards
to what it is that's happening here very
own actually goes to the Justice League
Watchtower and we basically get just
like this nostalgia trip of all this
stuff the Justice League's confiscated
from different villains whenever they
executed our different campaigns and
there's all different kinds of things
here you know for example the old school
vessel that belonged to Lex Luthor you
know the the TV show version the Super
Friends version of the you know his own
super super villain team I can't know
what it is they were called but we get
all these different iterations all these
different little knickknacks and so on
and so forth from stories and years past
some of which are from before the new 52
it was really kind of crazy to see all
this unfold but what Barry does is he
goes back and he recaptures the cosmic
treadmill now if the cosmic treadmill
serves a lot of different purposes in DC
Comics but it basically allows Barry
Allen traverse the entirety of the
landscape travel travel to time travel
to other dimensions to basically go from
one place to the next it's just kind of
a way for him to break various time
barriers and so on and so forth but one
of the other reasons why this matters is
because of the fact that it allows Barry
Allen to do so with other people coming
along and the reason why I say that is
because in a lot of ways Barry Allen's
power was nerfed pretty hardcore in the
new 52 really in the Silver Age when he
was at the height of his power when he
was super strong he can actually vibrate
through frequencies and he could
essentially reach other realities the
problem with this was that unless he had
been to that of the dimension before he
couldn't directly go there so it would
be like if you had the ability to
teleport and he wanted to teleport to a
place you've never seen where you've
never been there you've never seen it
you don't know where you would be
teleporting to I might as well just be
it
and space of blackness and darkness and
a great big huge void you know it's
easier to teleport to Paris if you've
been to Paris or if you've seen pictures
of Paris have you seen a picture of the
Eiffel Tower or something along those
lines and so again with regards to the
cosmic treadmill is it allows a lot more
control it allows him to basically
chrome in on something to trace a
particular signature and then follow
that signature to its source and that's
exactly what he's doing here the
question is if his own energy signature
was on the corpse of eobard thawne and
what he wants to do is trace that energy
signature to where it came from the
cosmic treadmill is the most reasonable
way for him to do it and so what ends up
happening here is of course Batman being
Batman
just like follows him because he's like
yeah I know I was on my deathbed and I'm
clinging on to dear life but I've got to
go anyway because the story wouldn't be
complete if I wasn't here it's cool to
see it's really interesting to see but
the fact remains oh it is in this video
that we talk about that I totally forgot
I totally forgot see how excited I am
I kept thinking it was a third party did
we get to talk man you guys are in for
it and it goes there for a treat okay
here's where I think DC is going with
this here's what I think DC is doing
with this okay this is going to be an
adventure matter so excited this is why
I'm doing these videos like I could get
so excited I just don't say it man yeah
yeah um so here's the deal jumping on
the cosmic treadmill and heading to
their destination what they start doing
is they start passing all these
different versions of the lives of that
of the Batman character the Wonder Woman
character the Aquaman character you know
the Green Lantern the flash characters
over the course of their publication
history dating all the way back to the
Golden Age of comics now initially
Batman's question is are these alternate
realities now very different gilma
direct-response very simply says Wally
told me that years were taken from us so
the implication seems to be here here's
what I think DC is going with this the
implication seems to be here I think
that they are eliminating everything in
terms of reboots the whole nine yards I
think this is the reboot to end all
reboots where new 52 I'm sorry yeah
where new 52 was a reboot where Infinite
Crisis was a reboot Final Crisis crisis
on Infinite Earths zero hour crisis
sometime to a degree I think DC instead
of starting at 5:00 or instead of
starting at you know 6 and then they're
going back and they're starting at 0 I
think they're basically wiping
everything that happened between the
time the superheroes first appeared and
the time they appeared now and they're
basically saying here's where it all
basically starts like here is the
definitive continuity of these
characters and it's not the first time
they did that following the events of
Zira our crisis and time DC gave us like
this timeline of when superheroes first
started showing up they give us a
timeline of like when Superman first
showed up when Bruce Wayne first became
Batman so on and so forth imagine that
for a second imagine that you go and you
buy you know after this whole GC Rieber
thing is done imagine that you buy like
you know Batman number one or something
along those lines all right imagine that
like the news stories that come after
this whole Watchmen versus Justice
League whatever this is
imagine the news stories are basically
giving you everything that happened
between the time that the superheroes
first showed up up until now and so DC
can pick and choose they could say okay
let's treat this like we've never done a
reboot before let's just let's just
create like a whole new landscape then
let's say okay here's Batman the only
things that happened in Batman's life of
any significance is that his back was
broken by Bane hush show doubt that made
his life hell for a little while you
know maybe he died or something along
those lines and here is a timeline of
when those things happen clearing out
all the lackluster stories clearing out
all the bad stories and only keeping the
good ones so that if you are a Batman
fan DC says if you want to know what
happened in Batman's life up to this
point read this this this this and that
story and you will be all set that's
where I think they're going with this
that's what I think they're doing with
this now I could be wrong entirely I
could be completely wrong but that's
what I think they're doing I think
they're basically saying that there was
no crisis on defenders there was no zero
hour crisis in time there was no
Infinite Crisis or Final Crisis
everything that happened has all taken
place like it's all just kind of there
you know and there are some stories
there are some things that might be you
know a little weird in terms of
continuity but on the whole everything
is there everything that we knew and
loved before the new budget - is all
still there so I'm really kind of hoping
that happens but the fact remains that
the whole cosmic treadmill more or less
goes off track is if they hit a wall
some energy basically knocks them off
their destination and the result is they
end up landing in a place that they're
not wildly familiar with only for a
Batman to start poking around and for us
as the reader to start seeing pictures
that we're familiar with start seeing a
Batcave that we're familiar with a
Batcave that
we saw in the flashpoint universe and
was home to Thomas Wayne when that being
said guys if you are new here the
comments explained make sure you guys
have the sub button to become part of me
Rob cork have you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop on like and
yeah that's lifting it up I will catch
you guys in the next video peace
[Music]